I am unstoppable I'll be down to kill
that dude yeah but when you chill with
him is he always dropping motivational
[ __ ] oh I shut the [ __ ] no I don't think
so I mean a goddamn gordita I think he's
actually calm just shut up or DITA
what's it called is a gordita from Taco
Bell they still make those yes and is he
dropping like is he dropping motivation
why are you suing he's yelling at you
for eating I don't think he's yelling I
just like I just I picked him Kanzi
dropping motivate it's not a good idea
you know you need to run it Brendan
Brendan I want you I want you to look me
in the eye right now you [ __ ]
wait no he does is he sure does I get
you out of your comfort zone I changed
your whole rhythm of thinking I stopped
your brain right now I stopped the noise
new brand new [ __ ]
stop being that goddamn gordita you
piece of [ __ ] well that's thank you you
can aim with your father that gordito
resemble some fathers do I need it did
he blow any do you hate ambitions on
your life do you hate your dad can you
put cheese all over that gordita take
that cord eater put it in your face was
that ago is that nacho supreme true or
I'll represent your mouth to throw it up
and spit it messy in there spin it oh my
messy there's hot sauce all over it's
spicy like your mother
hey you fat piece of [ __ ] let me just
get through my meal he's not fat don't
call me fat I will punch you in the face
right now I'm Way bigger I'll take your
head squeeze it like a mouse creature
grapes oh my oh my fingers feel my pen
down our fingers no those are not two
bunches of bananas around your head
those are my fingers feel them right now
look me in the eye thumbs on your eyes
and I push it until you're batshit crazy
you don't you're batshit crazy you don't
think Tony Robbins has a pterodactyl
educational dish you're [ __ ] crazy
boy if you think my thing isn't just
like you can do it if some dude was like
some dude I couldn't do it cuz as your
Tom his dick would be like you know the
thing the thing is man what I want hey
Tony
he made this get your successful dick
out of my face he made this guy roar
because you're a lamb you're a lamb
you're a lamb I want to hear you or you
know if you have to me I'd say [ __ ] you
dude the guy goes oh and tell him that
kinda lame and turn around turn around
Gus
that's a [ __ ]
that's all for can draw and do highways
keep going from in my I was in my living
room I was like he was so scary he was
so I would be in the back like this as
they're doing that to me yes can't get
my [ __ ] money back you Tony Robbins
let's take it easy if you're doing this
let's take it easy you're doing this if
you're doing or excuse me sir have you
ever heard of Nintendo glove came out
all 30 years ago
same [ __ ] yes but it was just real
shitty can really stick well no I think
it's gonna stick with the technology of
catch-up and it can get better but well
no I would imagine though if you could
do and correct me if they have this
already it's one thing if I had avert if
I had virtual goggles on and I'm in a
space where I'm trying to kill bad guys
and I have a gun and I can like a gun
yeah I can point it and I'm shooting
it's basically virtual simulation yeah
that was not physical right yeah they've
had that for about 10 years banks all
just hear me out you have a console it's
there you have two controllers with the
controller screen it connects to the TV
huh now call me crazy now there's no
I've been thinking about this forever
my character is it's a hedgehog alright
he's a jock
he collects coins his best friend is a
fox don't steal this idea
his name is Sonic the Hedgehog the Fox
name is tails okay and you collect
Cornell's tails tails well I got one
more for you you have four turtles all
right four [ __ ] pet turtles they fall
into some weird booze they become ninjas
their dad is a rat hear me out follow
follow he's a rat he teaches them
Taekwondo they fight crime you know it's
funny no idea off the top my head sounds
so insane and somebody actually did that
and it worked I was like that was
alright I got one more I don't want two
brothers they're plumbers one wears red
one wears green they jump on mushrooms
they go through portals their enemy I
just hear me I know so who's the enemy
is a snapping turtle laughing turn Ange
Koopa that's names Koopa okay and then
there's because he stole a princess I
know but you I'm you're like
or the plumbers Kings they're not
they're just they love this princess to
try and save the princess from the
attacking snapping turtle okay but wait
so they also collect coin what did I do
with the coins hmm I haven't got that
yeah you gotta let you got to work this
out war dude if you want me to buy this
you gotta work it out Oh what did you do
I sell you on the to plumbers brothers I
think so so far what would you call it
though I'm just trying to it has to be
ethnic ethnic all right hold on there's
your say no they can't be from America
cause Hamid brothers mmm Muhammad
brothers Muhammad Muhammad Muhammad
brothers it's me Muhammad oh well that's
not gonna work
why'd you go Harmon it's me Mom I didn't
say mo o H aah you know I'm its me
Muhammad no got it it's me Mario it's me
Mario that's Mario Brothers third
tallien maybe they [ __ ] love pizza
yeah good stuff all right well I'm gonna
make him black don't do it's me Tyrone
white this is black mr. lewin brothers
why do they have to be sharks like that
don't like this well buck hey bro it's
my [ __ ] video game just I'm just
pitching ideas out here all right
we're trying to save that [ __ ]
princess okay
Emer you're not in this season game it's
my idea
on the UC 202 media call last week Conor
McGregor said quote for the most part
these WWE guys are [ __ ] to be honest
they're messed up [ __ ] fair play to
brock he got in there and fought but at
the end of the day he was juiced up to
his [ __ ] high ball so how can I
respect that every big name in the WWE
is coming after him now on Twitter hold
on let's let's hear it let's get you up
on the are you are you a wrestling fan
perfect get up there Roger Blair Roger
Roger what's your take on this Conor
basically calling out the entire W but
he did single out the rock and Vince
McMahon egos there's a
couple bosses out there the rock huge
Vince McMahon owner and I free I think
one more was it seen our assumption not
seen a triple Eight's who also runs the
dough do he Connor needs to leave the
rock alone we got fest and fears 12
coming up you excited for that not so
much okay yeah I didn't see the original
tweet that Connor
shot out but I did see the follow-up
because apparently he got a ton of
backlash over so even in his follow
tweet he was like sorry I offended you
but I'll still [ __ ] you all up yes and
he's correct yes kind of there I don't
have an issue with it and people think
Connor plans I don't think you did I
think in general most athletes who have
any experience in real sports don't view
the WWE as is you can't take him serious
you just can't now Connor goes beyond
and above calling [ __ ] I won't call
them [ __ ] no I think their job is
tough oh yeah now compared to UFC
fighter it's nothing compared to real
competition as far as MMA NFL rugby
basketball hockey lacrosse any real
sport became compare the two ones acting
entertainment granted their bodies take
abuse was just not you can't compare I
want to call them [ __ ] are far from
[ __ ] but they're not they're not
they're not sport athletes collar just
he just you know him everything he does
yeah so ball the double you guys tweeted
I'm talking [ __ ] which makes Connor more
famous just get them more attention of
Christ yeah and the the the quote about
Brock was hilarious
of course he's juice to the [ __ ]
gills to fight yeah yeah so we already
know you or at least you're watching the
Olympics but what are your favorite
sports in the Olympics for me yes well
I'm telling include Winter Olympics no
summer kids Kurt right now Brian but let
me just say ice skating figure skating I
don't
gymnastics so you know and female mostly
female I don't know why not cuz I'm I
agree the male gymnastic a freak me out
yeah they look like they smell like
cabbage that weird yes it is it looked
like they smelled like that that
cabbage I've never seen mix they get it
to lunch training we must get muscle
they're tiny though they're tiny I'm
sweating they have chalk Aloha yeah
they're tough small you're small strong
it and they look like this olive oil all
right and then I like gymnastics
I like figure skating eyeliner I like
wrestling I like I don't watch a lot of
non-olympic sport keep going it is
actually wrestling is are they back in
yeah it'd be news to me are they back in
judo I like I love watching judo what's
going on um I like the weightlifting and
I love track and field except for speed
walking and I don't care so much about
the marathon have seen it
but I like the javelin look forward to
the [ __ ] real unreal anyway yeah I
like it all but gymnastics the the
figure skating Oh diving I like diving
I don't like a braid don't care about
swimming ooh no swimming to get you get
your blood pressure because they do the
relay and Mars a man or the Mars Michael
Phelps lar team last night them boys
went hard it's exciting I watch it but I
resent it yeah it is this oh yeah
homeboy from our boy that gold medalist
the guy who [ __ ] dominates the black
hood from yes from Nebraska
he's [ __ ] yeah he's the gold medal
guy he's on the cover a bunch [ __ ] and
then Allyson Felix hashtag from Denver
hashtag hometown ran track at USC she's
the front-runner for the women track
team beast ladies and gentlemen it just
got even more muscular up in here beef
la real beefy beefy beefy I'm between
two beef cakes letting German Sean
lights out Merriman joins us on the
fighter and the kids and I have two
questions but that's the first my I'll
never forget my introduction to the NFL
my rookie year we were playing the
Steelers and Jerome Bettis was back
there the bus the bus and so you know
you hear about all these guys right
and I got up four big players so where's
Ben Roethlisberger's over the edge of
Rome Bettis and Hines Ward so I'm seeing
all these guys and I'm like I'm gonna
I'm not trying to knock him out right
I'm gonna try to hit his ass hard
because that's what I was accustomed to
in college and they ran a dive for a
dive play and of course I'm playing
outside linebacker and I kind of fold
over nobody blocks me and he's running
to the opposite side he's running
straight ahead so I see Jerome Bettis
huh yeah i'ma lay his ass ready and I
see it on my ear holy imma ear hold him
right in the side or I shot him I'm Jes
I'm thinking in the game this isn't a
game I'm real-life at the top this big
gets big ass out or 270 or whatever he
was I go and I hit him and I he was so
big and around I couldn't wrap my arms
all the way around him right so I
started from like a little around his
shoulder pads and I slid down I slid
down two to three more yards I slid down
two or three what y'all so five yards I
end up catching his shoe strings and
then he fell and I remember hitting the
ground on my chest and like oh my god
wouldn't the hell was that
what's funny about him is I've actually
hung I was in a group when he was in
Vegas I was around and I was studying
him and I thought to myself he doesn't
when I see you there's no question
you're a professional athlete pro
football player Jerome went in clothing
can actually look a little bit maybe
maybe a little bit the Hall of Fame yeah
it doesn't look like what he wear you
wouldn't say that's one of the best
running backs ever you you hit it it's
like a movie you walk out there and you
see the crowd you hear people but you
hear more of a wave right you so you
hear the people chanting you run through
the smoke in the tunnel and then boom
now you have the sky and all these
people you got the cameras and you got
to stuff over your head Georgia Tech my
freshman year we played Georgia Tech and
I was like oh my god this is Georgia
Tech on the other side and that was also
the first game that people really found
up there like the meaning the lights out
you know I got in the game in a wide
receiver by the name of Watkins came and
caught a ball across the middle and I'm
dropping into coverage and I see him and
I know that by the throw the ball to
when I take off run and I just
launch at him boom I hit him and I got
up he hit the ground the back of his
head hit the ground which kind of
knocked him out and I got up and flicked
the switch that's on my right forearm
and as I'm just moving my hand up and
down a crowd gets louder and the crowd
gets louder and I started to jump up and
down because I get excited from the
crowd and they got louder so I go harder
and that's kind of where that hold
lights out in the SAC Dance Crew it you
had to kind of scratch her yeah I want
to kind of just flick the switch with
one finger on that on my forearm and
there's a crowd it just they they over
excited me and I got super excited and I
started to jump up and down along with
them I got to the sideline and my coach
Ralph region he said if you ever do that
again you'll never play on this field
again and I and I put my head down as
I'm going down my teammates everybody
came and smack him in the head my other
coaches hey what was that move you did
we loved it I was like I'm keeping that
see they see that I don't know I agreed
not being disrespect I don't think
that's disrespectful I think it's better
for the sport when you give these guys
show them yes and I like how it just be
yourself man like if you censor everyone
it's like dude like we don't feel like
we love watching our lady like we like I
think people it's part of personal
entertainment we like guys to have some
color is there any is there any truth I
remember there's a rumor the lights out
thing happened in college or in high
school with you cuz you knocked out
three or four dudes and yeah a single
game for yeah for our high school and
they're like god damn I'm sure they knew
I bet these four little dudes like
what's the worst that can happen now
let's go see how it goes it's true it's
funny because you're in high school so
we didn't have the YouTube sensations
and all this stuff to go around so
became almost a myth right and I'm going
around I got to college and a pro like
hey did you really knock out four guys
so so yeah that's what happened my
sophomore year we were playing a game we
were at home and I knocked out the first
three guys in the first half and one in
the second half and then after the game
people came right up to names like aw
man you knock those guys lights out and
I said yeah call me lights out that's so
my one of my role models growing up was
junior se
look man I mean do I wore 55 he was my
guy I put the visor on I'd wear shirt he
had a brand say ow
yeah let's say yeah it was in like
JCPenney who's like when the first
athletes really mark it out like that
kind of what you're doing now
well you did you have a relationship
with jr. say out cuz you if you
mentioned San Diego Chargers you cannot
do it without saying June you can't it's
impossible and he to me Junior's say I
was always like a superhero right
because here I guess if you're in in San
Diego you know West Coast so well if
you're everywhere else you know Junior
Seau as a player that you know playing
what almost 20 years or 20 years or
whatever it was its outstanding
incredible linebacker just a beast you
know that part of them but with the
people in California in Southern
California and San Diego and in that
area all the way down from here at all
down to San Diego you know junior se out
is all everything this is somebody who
dedicated and devoted his time to the
community did everything for everybody
spent more time working out and giving
back just you can't even really put it
into words his work at the guy remember
in 2005 when I got trapped I got a
chance to you know work out with him
during offseason and he should have this
thing called like The Breakfast Club you
know work out like six o'clock in the
morning
Jill buggers in his uh like 15th year
something like that at the time maybe if
you know maybe longer or around that
time I'm like what is he or thirteenth
whatever it was and then why is this how
he how yeah you know you're double-digit
yeah you and double-digit years and
you're still going around like this it's
ridiculous and I had a mark already
right in my head mentally I didn't want
to be junior see I want to be better
than junior saying I want to do the best
Shawne Merriman and I'll never forget
after my rookie year it was a big
article that came on the unit you're
being on compare me to compare me to
junior se out and I was like oh no God
please it makes sense though like it
yeah but you're talking about 11 or 12
rate Pro Bowls I mean yeah somebody who
just if you say it's Andy even without
football
something about San Diego you
automatically start thinking the junior
say out what he did so they even get
compared or in the same breath was that
out I just didn't even know how to
handle and I remember looking at that
newspaper there's unit reviewing I put
it down and I was like huh I want to
read press it's kind of like like people
always talk about how good off see good
of a player junior said we all know that
Hall of Famer won the best of all time
to me one of the signs even though he
was dealing with CT though probably the
worst we've ever heard of from NFL
player so bad where he shot himself but
he did it in a way where he wanted his
brain to be studied so other guys didn't
have to go through what he was doing
think about this some and said please
analyze my brain because this is why I'm
doing this that's nuts and that despair
and his you know I was really like I
went balls deep enough just reading
about juniors my favorite player and his
wife was saying how you know his
mentality changed from the CT and in he
was having dark days but the one thing
he could always rely on was the ocean
you'd always got this way would serve
any surf knots not when he loved the
[ __ ] out of it then she said she
remembers and this is like two days
before he died maybe day before he dies
he went out to the ocean and she went
out there just to you know check him out
what he's doing and he's sitting on a
surfboard and miserable and she was like
oh [ __ ] what are we gonna do cuz that
was like it the one thing he had and
then shortly after that off so you guys
know how that movie ends but he you want
to talk about a guy who was just so
selfless and just wanted to help people
out in the most desperate times he
donated his brain he's the first guy to
do it
incredible it's not it's actually heroic
and I saw in I remember you know just
the passion he played with and his best
friend this white guy I was at a UFC
event and his friend was backstage there
was someone and we're taking a piss and
he had no idea I love June I thought it
was all Brendan Schaub right away yeah
he goes yeah you were one of juniors
favorite fighters I mean whoa whoa what
the [ __ ] did you just say yeah tears man
yeah oh yeah here's man no because I'm
an actor yeah he's a guy left you out
yeah Sean I'm I'm on your fanboy now
right now you're keeping it to yourself
yeah I may win a small room I gotta keep
my composure you not trained with luck I
started with Jay a long time going like
2005-2006 and I was in San Diego around
a lot of guys who was training you know
from a San Diego all the way up to her
vine and OC area Temecula was a bunch of
guys I used to go train with it to make
you all the time like the you obviously
you're aware of it there's like a ton of
rumors around you fighting or doing WWE
like I feel like you're always around it
yeah I love the new explain yeah I mean
well first of all I'm a huge WWE fan and
I actually got a chance to go spend some
time and train at the facilities in
Orlando what was that like it was hell
don't get me wrong I loved it but it was
a different kind of training right so
you go and you're going nonstop for an
hour and you're flipping you're doing
handstands landed if you don't land on
that mat right you can forget about it
and none of the ropes and I don't know
if people are just like understand this
but under those robes in the ring it's
it's metal it's steel yeah
so you hit those ropes yeah it's fine to
watch the matches on TV but if you hit
those ropes in practice a hundred times
you're gonna be bruised and calloused
and the object of it is to hit it so
much they get callous enough where it
doesn't hurt anymore so that's the
mindset of it's gonna take some time
check all the time and then to which I
didn't mind you know they had the wwx
which is you know they get moved up from
it's like a minor feeder get yeah
exactly what it's huge it's everywhere
oh yeah people love yeah they loved it
and they had all their talent and
personalities you have to jump into
character and at the time guards are so
dusty Rhodes was kind of the head of
your personality and your character and
he calls everybody up there and you work
on your character once a week you called
it then you got to go in front everybody
so I was down there trained and I'm
thinking I'm just down at training and
we're walking down there a few days and
was the goal to actually pursue pro
wrestling
yeah Oh how would your name have been
next one what is the most surprising
thing about the inner workings of the
NFL as an organization has there ever
been something that you've just said
like I can't believe this is how they do
like um yeah the the craziest thing I've
ever seen will not be crazy I've seen a
bunch of crazy stuff but one of the
craziest things I've seen was a guy who
got traded and didn't know he we were in
the locker room and we were watching
ESPN and his name went across the bottom
of the ticker card and we were sitting
there reading I'm not gonna because I
want to throw him under the bus so I'm
on the other charges just for the
charges and we sit in the locker room
and he didn't know his name
like flickered across the bottom ESPN he
got traded and he was like what you
didn't know and we were sitting in
locker room chilling we just got out of
the shower hands dirty and he got he got
traded his mom and right there you know
same same type of thing happened to me
I'm watching the draft I think it was
like a note 9 Oh 2010 and they drafted
Larry English who ended up you know
playing there playing behind me in San
Diego and it's all Chris Braman grabbed
his ear like he's listening to something
out we're hearing Shawne Merriman is on
the trade and block something nobody
told me I'm the last person you know
that's not some of the craziest things
that have